so there's this excellent book that
people should read uh called viral the
search for the origin of kovi 19. uh
matt ridley and uh alina chan i think
alina is in mit
probably the broad yeah
yeah yeah
so she uh i heard her in an interview
give this analogy of
unicorns yeah and uh
where
basically somebody writes a proposal to
add horns to horses
the proposal was rejected
and then a couple of years later or a
year later a unicorn shows up
in the place
where they're proposing to do it and
that's so i had and then everyone was
like yeah it's natural origin it's like
it's possible it's natural origin like
we haven't detected a unicorn yet and
this is the first time we've detected a
unicorn or
it could be this massive organization
that was
planning is fully equipped has like a
history of being able to do this stuff
as the world experts to do it has the
funding has the motivation to add horns
to horses and now a unicorn shows up and
they're saying nope
your first question of how do i get to
my 85 and here's here's a summary
of that of that answer and so it's what
i said in my 60 minutes i interviewed a
long time ago of all the gin joints and
all the towns in all the world the quote
from from casablanca
and so of all the places in the world
where we have an outbreak of a sars-like
bat coronavirus it's not in the area of
the natural habitat of the horseshoe
bats it's the one city in china
with the first and largest
level four virology lab which actually
wasn't even using it they were doing
level three and and level two for this
work
where they had the world's largest
collection of bat coronaviruses um where
they were doing aggressive experiments
designed to make these scary viruses
scarier
where they had been part of an
application
to insert a furan cleavage site able to
infect human cells
and where
when the outbreak happened we had a
virus that was ready ready for action to
infect humans and to this day better
able to infect humans than any other
species including including bats and
then from day one
there's this massive cover up and then
on top of that
in spite of lots of efforts by lots of
people there's basically no evidence for
the natural origin hypothesis everything
that i've described just now is
circumstantial but there's a certain
point
where you add up the circumstances and
you see this seems pretty pretty likely
i mean if we're getting to a hundred
percent we are not at a hundred percent
by any means there still is a
possibility of a natural origin and if
we find that great but from everything
that i know that's how i get to my 85.
you